Hello world. It's Saroj and what
does the Anti Facebook look like?
Snapchat,
no.
Facebook's newsfeed Ai Algorithm is
causing some serious problems and in this
video we'll learn how
it works technically.
Then discuss some solutions to
the problems that it presents.
Facebook uses AI for pretty
much all of it's products,
whether it's showing you the
most relevant comments, fighting,
spammers or summarizing trending news
this year they've reached over 2 billion
monthly active users making it the
biggest social network in the world.
It makes sense.
They provide users with free services.
They can use messaging store as much of
their data on Facebook servers as they'd
like.
Host live streams all for free.
The way users actually pay for Facebook
is not what their money but with their
data. Anytime we use
Facebook, it learns about us.
Facebook knows which of its users have
depression, which ones are full of hate,
which ones are recently married,
where they live, et cetera.
This is very valuable information for
companies who have products or services
they would like to sell.
Facebook's business model centers around
giving advertisers access to a very
targeted audience.
Advertisers can choose the type of person
they'd like to promote their brand too
in detail,
and Facebook facilitates that process.
They pay Facebook for your data,
which means that when you use Facebook,
you, and specifically your
attention is the product.
This materializes in the way
Facebook's flagship product,
the newsfeed works.
Let's imagine we're Facebook and we want
to show a user the most optimal content
in their newsfeed such that they keep
their eyes on it as long as possible.
We've got a list of activities that
users have performed in the past called
events.
An event can be a post made by a friend,
a conversation between two friends on new
group being created, things like that,
and different users will interact
with these events in different ways.
One might like an event, the other could
ignore it, the other could reshare it,
and we can represent all of these
actions as numerical values and we can
represent all of this as a matrix.
The roads would be all the unique
users and the columns would be all the
possible events for Facebook.
This matrix would be bigger than
Apple's evaluation and we're making two
assumptions here.
The first is that users who interact
with events in a similar way share one or
more hidden preferences.
For example,
liking the same posts or
viewing the same article.
The second is that users with shared
preferences are likely to respond in the
same way to the same events.
Thus we are relying only on observed user
behavior here to make recommendations,
which is considered collaborative
filtering and a popular way to this is by
using a technique called
Matrix factorization.
Every entry in our matrix captures
a user's reaction to a given event.
That rating could be explicit directly
generated by user feedback or implicit
based on features like time spent
interacting with set events.
If a user has never rated an event,
the Matrix entry is zero.
Often in these type of matrices,
the majority of the entries are at zero.
We're assuming that there's a set of
features common to all of these events and
events differ in how they
express these features.
Each user has their own
reaction to each feature.
Independent of the events are users.
Events rating can be approximated then
by summing the users strengths for each
feature weighted by the degree to
which the event expresses this feature.
These features are hidden factors
we'll need to transform the matrix to
represent these hidden
factors using linear Algebra.
This is called low rank approximation.
It's the process of compressing the sparse
information in our matrix into a much
lower dimensional space.
Then we can calculate the rating of a
given user for a given event by taking the
dot product of two vectors,
which we're going to do in the context
of a neural network so that we can
leverage the fact that we have so much
data and computing power as Facebook.
The added terms like the weight matrix
will help us optimize our predictions
over time. The output will be
the combination of both vectors.
This output represents a prediction
of a user's rating for a given event.
We can then define a loss
function to measure the
accuracy of this approximation.
It sums the square difference between
the approximate rating and the actual
rating from the training set.
Lastly,
we can perform gradient descent to use
that computed error to update our weights
and every iteration that
error will get smaller.
While our predicted user ratings,
we'll get better.
Ai optimized ads are different
than regular ads because
it's no longer a one way
relationship.
It's two way you view the ad,
but the ad also views you and how you
react so they can manipulate you subtly.
Facebook decided to not
only perform surveillance on
literally everything you do
to advertise to you.
They also decided to perform
direct behavior modification.
Human survival has necessitated that
our brains pay more urgent attention to
possible bad outcomes than to good ones.
Facebook's attention optimizing AI has
learned to exploit this and to keep us
engaged and manipulate our behavior.
For example,
making people argue leads to more
engagement which leads to more attention,
which leads to more ad revenue,
human decency, kindness, empathy.
These things are not
profitable for companies like
Facebook all operating under
the business of a tension maximisation.
This has resulted in a much more
polarized society globally where existing
opinions are reinforced endlessly and
arguments are encouraged by AI optimized
content. It's tearing apart.
The fabric of human society.
Never before has one entity been so
powerful to manipulate the psyche of 2
billion people.
The initial founders of Facebook,
including Sean Parker and
Chamath Palihapitiya have
both stated that they regret
the effects on society that
their business model has caused,
especially on children.
The short term solution to
this problem is awareness.
The more people that know just how good
Facebook's AI is at manipulating them in
ways they don't even fully understand yet,
the more likely they'll
be to protect themselves.
The center for humane technology has a
list of ways to take back control of your
attention from these social networks.
Some suggestions include turning off
all notifications except from people and
going gray scale to avoid the positive
reinforcement that colorful icons are
designed to unlock in our heads.
A more ambitious solution is
to build the anti Facebook,
a social network that uses
a different business model.
[inaudible] is one example of this.
Their business model is facilitating
users sending funds to other users,
not advertising.
That's an optimization objective that
can be much more easily aligned with the
users wellbeing than eyeball seconds.
Another thing to note about [inaudible]
is that you can peep and tweet at the
same time,
which is an effective way to erode the
network effects that protect more popular
social networks.
You can even easily sync your
followers from Twitter to p path.
It's features like that that show us that
it doesn't have to be inconvenient for
users to find an alternative to Facebook.
Another example is mastodon.
This is a Twitter clown that anyone can
host instead of one provider in charge
of the newsfeed. There are
several. It's a federated network,
more decentralized than Facebook.
It provides the same resources,
but with the added ability to exit it.
Commoditizes feed providers.
If one provider is starting to
put too many ads on their feed,
a user can just switch to another.
There are some technical challenges to
building decentralized applications and I
tell them all in my past course
and in my pass book on the topic,
there's also the possibility of
Facebook be centralizing itself.
Facebook's original mission was
establishing an Internet identity.
That's what made them
different from my space.
It seems like a natural continuation for
them to try and position themselves to
be the root of human identity
on the Internet and having
a unique crypto address
not owned by anyone would do just that.
Just a few months ago,
they announced their biggest
ever management reshuffling,
which included the launch of an
exploratory blockchain group that reports
directly to the company's CTO.
If Facebook released
their own crypto currency,
they could pay their users for
engaging with their platform,
say one face coin per uploaded photo.
This would also give
equity to all of its users,
which would retain them and get
them to help grow the platform.
Because right now that growth is
stagnating as users wake up to Facebook's
problems. It could even give them
voting rights as to how Facebook is run,
which would increase
their brand reputation.
This would be profitable for Facebook
and it would help solve their alignment
problem because through
this new business model,
they'd be more inclined to show users
content that would benefit them and paying
over 2 billion people globally for their
data starts to look like a universal
basic income which would offset some of
the effects that automation technology
will have on labor based jobs.
Speaking of a new class of jobs,
linear envisions that who start seeing
mediators of individual data or mids
start forming as well.
This is a nonprofit organization that
negotiates data royalties for groups of
people with similar interests.
For instance,
a botanist who likes to hike could join
a mid for people who compiled useful
photographs and data about trees
in certain regions of the world.
That data would be valuable to certain
companies and a protocol like open mind
could facilitate this exchange of data
and capital in a decentralized way.
So even though Facebook's business
model is bad for the human psyche in the
short term,
we can protect ourselves by adopting anti
addiction techniques so that we get as
much of the good from
social media as we can.
While avoiding the bad along the way,
we can build other social apps that use
different business models to provide
people with alternative options.
And who knows,
maybe Facebook will become the anti
Facebook ushering in a new era of data
transparency with the focus on human
wellbeing instead of attention.
What do you think?
What is the Anti Facebook look like?
Share your thoughts in the
comments section. Please subscribe.
And for now I've got to use Twitter,
so thanks for watching.